after nearly five years of violence the
war in Yemen is showing no signs of
ending this hospital is filled with
government soldiers and civilians
injured in Saturday's attack on a
military camp in the region of Maariv
more than a hundred who killed
it was around sunset prayer we prayed
and then we sat down then the missile
hit it was around 6:30 and for 10
minutes or so I couldn't feel anything
around me so many of my friends were
killed this is all that's left of the
mosque that was targeted blown apart by
ballistic missile Yemen's government
backed by a Saudi UAE led military
coalition has blamed the Iranian backed
Houthi rebels and has vowed to retaliate
we would like to offer our condolences
to our nation our armed forces and the
families of the Fallen those who were
killed in a heinous attack by the
Iranian backed Houthi militias the
Fallen were true heroes soldiers in our
armed forces among the dead are also
civilians the war has created what the
UN has labeled the world's worst
humanitarian crisis since the start of
the conflict it's estimated more than
91,000 Yemenis have been killed and
another 3 million displaced by the
fighting Nicola gage al Jazeera